good morning everyone today is a really
big day as it is most days but today is
a very special day because the Apple
book is out now this isn't like the
MacBook or like some type of electronic
bug did you you know what my opinions my
head so it's a book of the last 20 years
of Apple products and it's dedicated to
steep is it dedicated to it is does it
show things that like is it up-to-date
yeah I think it stops at the Apple watch
I'm also writing snapchat spectacles if
you're wondering what's on my face shoe
exciting nobody's there cuz they're
getting the same results online Google
image no Jenna but it has inside details
from the design down I know I'm just
getting apartment this will be one of
those things that you keep like 50 years
and it's gonna be worth a fortune or not
I'm not sure
oh boy camping out for a book she told
me how my grubby little hands can't
touch it in as I walk Matt's grubby
hands can't touch them definitely not a
lot of touching he's gross I got a man
he's a gross boy if you want to touch my
book you need to wash your hand
I got a kid believe I'm first in line
for the book this is great are you sure
yeah today 216 this is but wait I should
probably get in line now and you should
get the sandwich because I don't want to
not be first in line I will hurt you
I'll see you mice I'll send you my
Starbucks the jackets lining up I bet he
is I'm well I'm getting in line get me
far wrong
I have to get a line I'll send you my
Star Trek's code so you can pay for it
I'll text it to you can't believe I'm
first in line this is so exciting I just
I just would like to thank you I'd like
to thank me like the big Jennifer going
at my Starbucks so this is a great day
it's a great day for everyone I don't
actually see any books in there
I think it's very exciting you think
okay it's 924
what do we do Jen would have hit another
book I need to get a dongle so we use
our timewise I'm just gonna take a look
at their dongles and see what they've
got but I definitely do need the USBC to
lightning it something that I didn't
realize I was like hey do you guys have
the books and she's like yeah you can
order them online I was like leading
fine print is not something that is my
specialty so I just ordered the books on
my phone and now we can pick them up as
soon as the store opens in 10 minutes
she said they're really big
like this big
oh they are they're having like a little
field trip and everybody's clapping for
them to come in it's like a product
launch which it is the book is out the
book
I like this one I said I bought it like
we'll let you know when you come pick it
up I was it okay pick it up
dongle download on O'Donnell Donald on
the wall
we have to wait because they're
preparing my order you could've had as
he just walked in there was like on the
book but I was worried that they were
gonna sell out it's a hot commodity
nobody in the Apple store even knows
that it's a thing I've asked four or
five people and they were all confused
they thought I was looking for a Macbook
like no I'm saying Apple book but I'm
not talking about a computer
items ready for pickup the small one is
still pretty good
okay so heavy should we just shoot a
horse them and they say no no Commission
well here's my coffee table and here's
my new coffee table book smells like
Apple of course app and then the book is
inside of another oh gosh that's cool
designed by Apple in California
dedicated to Steve Jobs introduction by
Johnny oh this is a book of very few
words
it's about our products the physical
nature and how they were made
beautiful
it's beautiful it's so so pretty
Wow this is how they make the cases
there we have it guys the new coffee
table books they carry so much for
watching let me know what you guys think
about the books do you think it's crazy
do you think it's ridiculous that this
is something that is near and dear to my
heart oh so I am very very happy I'll
see you guys in my next video have a
wonderful day bye the Space Gray it's in
a little case it's little box it's a
little bed it doesn't even have a smell
usually any time a lot of America
it's got a smell the first thing that we
have is is us DC charger something that
I already don't